next question if a person has to eat or
drink in order to save his or her life
does that um mean that they have to make
up that fast later on or is it accepted
that fast if a person is dying as you
say dying of hunger or dying of thirst
yes while fasting if he feels hungry and
thirsty and if he feels that if he does
not take something does not take some
food or does not take some water it will
damage some of his organs of the body if
he feel his life is threatened or may
cause a major damage to some of his
organs then if he breaks the fast to
save his life it is accepted Allah will
forgive him but he will have to make up
for his fast after the month of Ramadan
is over but if someone finds it hard
difficult to fast because if he's doing
a laborous work or he's finding
difficulties he's feeling thirsty in
this case breaking the fast is a sin but
if he's really dying of hunger and then
if he breaks Allah will forgive him but
have to make up for the fast lat go